this is a really unfortunate
story Joe Biden's younger brother Frank
has just shown up naked on a gay porn
app good night everybody I think you
know on that kind of a story I don't
even want to go any further uh Frank
Biden now the second Biden to show up
naked on the
internet uh he's on this gay porn app I
don't even know which one it's called
guys with ion.com not not a very
creative title is it uh this is
according to dailymail.com they've got
the naked selfie so this wasn't a candid
shot he was taking it of himself uh
Frank Biden says I have absolutely no
comment I could care less I have first
of all just to pause there the phras is
I could not care less I if you say I
could care less that means that you care
somewhat at least
so I don't mean to nitpick the grammar
that one drives me crazy though and it
actually might tell you a little
something about Biden's role in all of
this he says I could care less I haven't
even looked at it they must have hacked
my phone anything that is a revealing
picture of some kind is between Mindy
and me I guess his wife I really don't
want to start off my day this way
definitely didn't post it
anywhere maybe he was hacked people try
to hack our phones all the time even
just among conservative uh commentators
and activists and anyone with any public
profile so I wouldn't be surprised at
all if they're trying to hack the phone
of the brother of the president of the
United States the reason though that I'm
a little skeptical of the they hacked my
phone excuse is that this photo
apparently didn't just appear on guys
with I phones.com it showed up in
2018 so it showed up before Joe was
President it showed up after Joe was in
the senate for almost 50 years it showed
up after Joe was the vice president it
showed up at the one period of Joe's
life when he was in private
life and before he was president and
then the it's just kind of surface ing
now uh regardless of whether Frank Biden
is a deeply deeply closeted homosexual
or if he is just a victim of a hacking
or something my
takeaway my advice to
everybody stop taking naked pictures of
yourself stop it stop it whe it's
whether it's for your wife or your
husband or your boyfriend or your
girlfriend whether it's for some app
like this one a gay app or a straight
app or some kind of
polyamorous pan
gender otherwise imaginative kind of
what stop it nothing good will ever come
from you taking naked pictures of
yourself be normal stop being weird stop
being a weirdo weirdos take naked
pictures of themselves you should not
Endeavor to be like that you should
endeavor
to be normal good grief these people
right now go to genucell.com
everyone here at the office loves the
genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector you might
be asking what this product even does
well if you have sunspots dark spots
discoloration or dry skin the genus Cell
Dark Spot Corrector will help those
blemishes disappear Kimberly from
Youngstown Ohio says quote my appearance
has improved so much since using genus
cell I love all my genus cell products
and my skin looks younger now it's your
turn to feel like Kimberly but hurry
because this sale is ending very soon
take advantage of J's most popular
package which includes the Beloved Dark
Spot Corrector this package also
includes Jus cell's classic under eye
treatment you will get all of these
products from almost 70% off Jus cell's
so confident in their products you can
try them yourself completely risk-free
if you don't see immediate results you
will get your money back it's simple go
to Jus cell.com
KW Lees start looking years even decades
younger tomorrow say hello to the very
best skin that you've ever had at
jus.com that is Jus cell.com
Rudy Giuliani is suing Joe Biden for
defamation here's why it's a typical New
York Times malicious lie I do not have
an alcohol problem I have never had an
alcohol problem and the reason I told
you what I achieved is nobody could have
achieved that if they did when the hell
was I drinking I was working 24 hours a
day it's a big damn lie by a newspaper
that's a disgrace and by a reporter who
covered me used to cover me very very uh
in a very glowing way and now is vicious
and mean in what she does thank you and
it it's my press
conference vicious and mean and if it
weren't for the protections that the
Press gets with times against Sullivan I
mean she should be sued for liable she
should also be thrown out of the
profession for being a damn liar but
that's okay so Rudy while explaining his
defamation suit against Biden talking
about how all these other people are
defaming him too the latest attack is
that Rudy is an alcoholic and Rudy has a
good counterargument to this which is
I'm extremely productive okay I was the
most successful mayor in the history of
New York I had a very successful legal
Consulting business after that I'm on TV
24/7 I was the lawyer to the sitting
president of the United States I give me
a break when would I have been drunk I
was on camera most of the time and even
if you think I'm eccentric I probably
wasn't drunk so he's saying this is a
specific defamatory claim and I'm going
to sue and I'm going to go Sue all the
way up to Joe Biden does juliani have a
case a defamation case against Joe or
any of the bidens yes he does and not
just on something like you know a claim
of being an alcoholic Hunter Biden
during one of of his most infamous
interviews during the 2020
race claimed that Rudy Giuliani was a
wacko conspiracy theorist pedling a pack
of lies that Hunter Biden had taken
money on behalf of the Biden family from
crooked people around the world do you
regret being on the board to begin with
no I don't regret being on the board
what I regret is not taking into account
that there would be a Rudy Giuliani and
a president of the United States that
would be listening to this this
ridiculous conspiracy idea which has
again been completely debunked by
everyone it's been completely debunked I
wasn't getting money from Ukraine and
China and shaking down people on behalf
of my father the big guy who Rudy found
the laptop he found my laptop he found
my messages I know it says I gave a
bunch of money to my dad and I shook
down foreigners including the Chinese
Communist party for for tens of millions
of dollars but no I don't that's all
fake it's all been
debunked and then it was rebunk and it
then it was just proven to be true and
you know when you look at a a claim like
hey you drink too much that's probably
not going to hold up in a defamation
lawsuit but if Rudy is suing Joe Biden
for saying you know you're a Putin
stooge you're a Russian propagandist
you're that that really might and I I
encourage this lawsuit one CU I have a
real soft spot for Rudy Giuliani because
he's the greatest mayor in the history
of New York but two because Joe Biden
needs to be held to account for
his career for his half century of
defamatory lies this is a guy who
lies with with such ease that I don't
think he even understands what the truth
is anymore this is a guy who lied about
the the the man who accidentally in this
horrible accidental car accident killed
his wife killed uh Joe Biden's wife and
Biden had acknowledged the man he wasn't
drunk he was it was just a horrible
horrible accident and the Man I mean he
just was racked with guilt for the rest
of his life and then Biden on the
campaign Trail decides he's going to
start claiming that the man was a drunk
driver this is this is Joe Biden a man
who speaking to audiences will just make
up facts about his son about his career
about things he said about things he's
voted on beliefs he's held he just lies
with impunity and so I'm all for it Rudy
baby take this guy to the cleaners
please boy what a great clip that was
now you got to ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael nlls Show YouTube channel
we'll see you next time